and welcome to Hannity and tonight
Straight Ahead we will bring you the
very latest from the House of
Representatives and the speaker battle
also low lights from Joe Biden's very
alarming interview on CBS in 60 minutes
let's say in a word the president looks
unwell but apparently we'll soon travel
to Israel but first we start with a Fox
News Alert it is 900 p.m. on the East
Coast 6:00 p.m. on the west coast it is
4:00 a.m. in Gaza all eyes are once
again on the Gaza Strip where we are
just one week removed from the worst
terrorist attack in Israel's history now
the number has gone up 1,400 were killed
in just one day if you just for
population that is roughly equal to over
37,000 uh Americans murdered right here
if we were to compare populations babies
we know they were set on fire we know
many were beheaded we know women were
raped we know entire families brutalized
in their own homes nearly 300 Israelis
and Americans including men women and
children were kidnapped by the terrorist
group Hamas they are now being held
hostage inside of Gaza one-year-old
babies in captivity locked up by
terrorists in underground tunnels Now
videos of Hamas terrorists with the
hostages including infants being put on
the internet why just to torture family
members in Israel but now frankly and
predictably some of the mob and the
media they are complaining that Israel
the victim of this terror attack that
they are the ones that are being
inhumane really take a look now look
Israel is not Russia Gaza is not Ukraine
it's a different situation but cutting
off supplies cutting off heat cutting
off water to
civilians what's the
difference well first thank you for
saying that Israel is not Russia because
Israel is not Russia second civilians
are civilians Jak civilians are
Civ and fake Jake is not particularly
bright how about the hostages fake Jake
if AAS let's say if they return the 300
innocent men women children that they're
now putting on the internet and videos
that were abducted uh then maybe Israel
can turn the lights on and the water
back on uh because if they turn it on
for the people of Gaza they're turning
it on for Hamas and by the way uh this
electricity and water that Israel
provides to Gaza because Hamas was more
interested in using international Aid
hundreds of millions of dollars to build
tunnels and Rockets rather than power
plants hospitals schools infrastructure
that is on them and for the record the
water is flowing into Southern Gaza
where Israel has instructed civilians to
flee so they can be safe with Tex with
airdrop leaflets and other forms of
communication but Hamas what are they
doing doing jack uh Jake they are
blocking the Palestinians from escaping
in order to use them as human Shields
but you got fake Jake you got fake news
CNN uh wrong as per usual and while
Israel tries to avoid human casualties
hokas looks to inflict pain and Death on
as many innocent Israelis and
Palestinians as possible they shoot
their Rockets from schools and from
hospitals why CU they know that if
Israel Strikes Back That innocent
civilians are killed they hide behind
human Shields all the time a MOS can
then score a cheap PR Victory with the
media mob war is terrible yes there are
innocent people that suffer uh there is
collateral damage as we call it it is
tragic it is unnecessary it is evil in
our time and Hamas will do everything
that they could do to exacerbate that
suffering every single death in this
conflict can be blamed on Hamas and
their supporters in Iran because of last
week's brutal terror attack Israel has
no choice they must defend their country
they must defend their lives and wage
total war against Hamas so they can no
longer use Gaza in close proximity to
Israeli cities as a launching ground for
the tens and tens of thousands of
rockets over the years they have fired
into Israel and by the way that goes for
anyone else that threatens their
existence take a look there are those
voices there across this region and
elsewhere
who say the price of military action is
too great that too many civilians are
now dying too many Palestinians are
already dying we're in a full War here
and the responsibility isn't on us you
should take that question straight back
to Hamas we are here because we have no
other choice now if Hamas actually cared
about the lives of innocent Palestinians
guess what they could surrender right
now war will be over now of course they
don't really care about the well-being
of of their fellow Palestinians and come
to think of it despite all the
widespread protests no one in the Arab
world really seems to care about the
fate of those innocent Palestinians uh
not one Arab country not one has been
willing to open their doors to
Palestinian refugees women and children
even not Egypt right next door not Syria
not Iraq not the ultra wealthy you know
Gulf States like Oman and Saudi Arabia
nor has the Islamic Republic of Iran
they're not opening their doors either
and meanwhile here at home and in Europe
massive so-called Pro Palestinian
protests are ongoing but no one at these
protests is calling on Hamas to put down
their arms stop committing these acts of
of Terror surrender and no one is
calling for Hamas to return the hostages
there there are no chance or prayers for
the families that are murdered inside of
Southern Israel or the babies burned
alive or beheaded you know some actually
praising Hamas and their brutal
terrorist tactics these protests are not
about Freedom or Humanity it's about
ethnic nationalism and of course hating
the quote Jewish people after Hamas
called for the day of jihad worldwide
last Friday anti-semitic attacks
exploding all over the world virulent
anti-Semitism on display in Belgium a
terrorist killed two people earlier
tonight near a Sweden Belgium soccer
match which is now suspended public
officials are now calling on all
citizens to avoid unnecessary travel in
Berlin City officials there instructing
the Jewish people there to hide symbols
that actually represent their faith what
decade is this for their own safety and
in the United States according to NBC
News law enforcement is now stepping up
patrols of synagogues and Jewish houses
of worship and businesses as calls for
attacks in our country intensify online
at the very same time illegal immigrants
from the Middle East we now are learning
are attempting to sneak into our country
quote in the Rio Grand Valley sector
officials there get this they have
apprehended 19 Iranians 17 syrians just
since Monday the US Mexican border is a
long way from Syria a long way from Iran
so who are they how did they get here
who paid for their trip why are they
here and there are growing concerns
among some experts that terrorist
sleeper cells are currently already
operating inside our country thanks to
Joe's open borders policies now s and a
half illegal immigrants uh no vetting at
all 99% by the way just so happened to
be uh led into the country and uh only a
mere 1% is told to return you know what
are they doing they're taking advantage
of Joe's wide open borders he's aiding
and abetting the process and thank
thanks to your President Joe Biden our
country is in extreme danger but let not
your heart be troubled right because
soon Joe is going to be headed to Israel
according to Anthony blinken win and
blinking but whatever comes from Biden's
trip to Israel the terror attack in
Israel last week it must be a lesson and
that is that we do not live in a bubble
intelligence is far from perfect we
cannot expect to be safe and secure with
unsecured borders especially on us on
our South we'll check with Florida
Governor Ronda Santos in just a minute
also breaking tonight the battle for
house speaker that is coming to a head
Will Jim Jordan clear the 217 vote
threshold after tomorrow's first uh
transparent vote because when they're in
conference they get to vote anonymously
because this is an important vot vote
and why is it a shock to certain
lawmakers and members of the media mob
all of you out there that you're as
truly a member of the press is daring to
ask Ed Representatives the so-called
public servants in this country if and
when they plan to wrap up this speaker
battle and reopen the people's house
amid growing chaos both at home and
abroad I have a lot more to say on this
later but I do have to chuckle that a
few of my questions simple questions
that I asked to some Republicans over
the weekend about the importance of
getting a speaker as soon as possible
show we have a few sensitive little
snowflakes in Congress here's the truth
they are the majority they need to act
like it no deals with the Democrats and
that would mean uh yeah no no temporary
solutions either elect a speaker get the
house open and start doing your job the
good news is the anonymous votes end
tomorrow and we will know and we will
see which Republicans understand what is
the importance of this moment in history
not only for the Republican party for
them to unite them to lead by reopening
the people's house while we have war in
the Middle East and war in Europe and
open borders and serious budget
deadlines oh I offer no apologies for
doing my job and seeking answers from
those elected public servants again key
word Servants of We the People we'll
have more on this coming up hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else